Rich Eisen host of the Rich Eisen show
on DIRECTV's audience Network and of
course the NFL Network founding host he
joins us here is Wofford a 15 seed is it
Wofford usually a tournament WOFF yeah
right yeah this is Watford oh I'm sorry
what I didn't hear that is that is the
tease I thought was a silent T I I think
first the Premier League would would
Watford be a 15 or 16 yeah hit 14 15 16
3 okay call rich joining me I didn't
look I didn't understand that do you are
you a crier we were just talking about
good Lord that yes I have you cried on
the air recently cried on the air
recently um I you know over what you
would expect yeah I mean I have any time
I anytime I talk about Stuart I get
choked up you know and I always think of
him around tournament time North
Carolina of you know January is the
anniversary of his passing but you know
I've got I do have the Vermeil in me
where I've got I can choke up a little
bit last sporting event that made you
cry maybe a movie I think I mean
Michigan hasn't won the national
championship since 1997
would that make you cry oh yes if
Michigan football 100 the name okay oh
yeah
Michigan basketball yeah I'm you know
and watching him last night was exciting
again too but yeah at sporting events
really don't choke me up it's movies and
TV shows and commercials that you
wouldn't think that I get choked up
McLovin is trying to get through the end
of this book and you have young kids
have you ever had Knuffle Bunny by
mobile was that like your jumbo was that
was that a jump word I mean a bunny no
no no with kids I mean seriously I can't
get through it yeah in the last page he
said he basically sends her spoiler
alert I mean come on you never know if
I'm gonna do yeah you know it's nug
elope with Knuffle Bunny at any point in
time go ahead let me see if it McLovin
can get through it I don't think I'm out
I'm out but the email to you guys
I heard what you were talking about
about how you know John Fogerty taking
your daughter to something that you
experience yourself maybe at her age
yeah um choked you up I had that moment
when I took zan who's now 9 I took
Xander to go see the Muppet movie the
remade Muppet movie forget the guy who
he was in um whose name I forget right
now and how I Met Your Mother
Jason right Jason Segel yeah
and it was a great very great version of
the Muppet movie was really neat and
they the Muppets fine with the story The
Muppets finally put on their show Dan
and the Muppet Show theme comes on and I
just choked me out we're playing it
right is that right I came here right
it's like if you could just imagine
somebody crying uncontrollably sobbing
to them headphones back there if you'd
like to put those songs for a little let
me go down memory lane let me see if we
can get some tears you don't really
think you get terribly emotional to this
music but I started crying and other
parents were kind of looking at who is
this guy having a nervous breakdown
because they're all bopping with their
children and I heard this and I'm like
wow Here I am with my son it says I
think it was his first movie too that I
took him to he's like 3 or 4 hmm I'm
getting choked up even just talking
about it right now
paulie's dad took him to Midnight
Express when he was 9 no come on a Bible
Midnight Express age 9 did the teacher
not to do drugs any it messed me up
forever yeah traffic anything internally
ever it's nothing ever petals in a Greek
prison you were never in Reverse though
anywhere near but I
Wow that's hardcore I remember my wife
and I were trying when my son was born
we were just desperate to get out and we
took him to see Cape Fear my son is
probably a month old and we're in the
back you know we welcome it where we're
in the back at the Bristol theatre and
we took we took my son to see
Cape Fear come out come out wherever you
are oh that and all these people are
like there's that scene in love us at
Sweet Home Alabama oh you you got a baby
in a bar with Reese Witherspoon I think
it is it's like you got a baby in a
movie theater yeah
seeing Cape Fear yeah Cape Fear not a
bad one uh all right while I have you
here yes sir
football wines yes sir Kirk D cousins
yes
how does he validate that contract in
the eyes of the you know the media is
gonna have high expectations oh you've
got to go to the Super Bowl is it three
years Super Bowl or they made it they
had a seven nothing lead on the
ultimately defending Super Bowl champs
in their house yeah so I guess you have
to at the very I mean if you really just
want to use that as the floor then he's
gotta keep that seven-point lead into
the second quarter if the next NFC
championship game that he has to get the
team to I mean it's it you have to take
them further than what Case Keenum took
them and you know III think that he he
has that ability it's gonna be uh it's
gonna be fascinating to me to watch this
play out certainly since it's all
guaranteed dollars I think he made the
right move I think going there as
opposed to maybe getting twice the years
and twice the money in New York City
where jet fans are gonna expect him to
go and win a championship on the spot or
he's gonna get the next big contract
after this yeah what makes make sense
yeah he's gonna have be 32 and probably
get another big deal yeah at 32 which is
the which is how old Aaron Rodgers is
right now so he he will it was a smart
move he's making a ton of money and he's
in a spot where he's got a chance to win
and I think you you might be taking a
trip to Philadelphia first Thursday of
the season and seeing him in that
building that I think NBC will run it
back with Kirk Cousins you think that'll
be the opening night men it's either
that or or stick Jerry Jones coming and
make him watch the Eagles raise their
banner which is particularly in your
face I would think
that I think those are the two things a
commissioner might want to do that to
Jerry Jones I mean I think its lawsuit
I don't know I did Dan I think right now
we're all starting from scratch I think
everything is now evened out apparently
rich and I were laughing about this
yesterday because we saw a quote from
Hugh Jackson he's the Cleveland Browns
head coach on his quarterback here's a
Hugh Jackson talking about Tyrod Taylor
when you go out and you do these
privates with the quarterbacks if you
bring them in here into Berea what would
you tell them about their their chances
of starting for this that Tyrod Taylor's
the starter okay they don't they don't
have another quarterback so Tyrod Taylor
has to be the starting point so this is
March and he's naming as starting
quarterback and and we're gonna hold him
to it yeah and or he should have said
Spurgeon wins not walking through that
door you know I mean okay in September
is Tyrod Taylor the starting quarterback
in clue you'd have to think so but they
have to draft somebody and they have to
draft him first overall I think I may be
the last time I was on the show um they
I said this they they have to call the
Giants and say to-date get them on what
do you what do you need for the second
overall pick use they've got three twos
left they used their three on getting
Tyrod Taylor
they have three twos left and just say
let's swap two to four what do you want
to this year to next year and and they
they go quarterback Barkley rip the knob
off we'll see you we'll see you middle
of Friday night that's it just just do
it and and end the drama do what you
need to do at the top of the draft go
bold if they already are doing that so
and and Tyrod Taylor would be a great
now here's oh no wait here's the quarter
we got the new phrase here for the other
said you know as you know set the edge
was the football phrase of 2017 yes the
clubhouse leader of the football phrase
of 2018 is bridge quarterback bridge
quarter everybody's got a bridge
quarterback Browns of bridge quarterback
the mister noon as you know the Buffalo
Bills now have a [ __ ] bridge
quarterback in Eugene McCarran ten
well I mean that that's a that's that's
a bubble bridge quarterback we don't
know case case came because they met had
you stick with Paxton Lynch draft
somebody fit overall to add to their
defense that's entirely possible if it's
Patrick's there's you know it keep to
leave was just sent out so he's he's a
bubble bridge quarterback the Jets as
you know have cornered the market on
bridge quarterbacks they have to and the
guy one of them actually has the word
bridge in his name so bridge quarterback
is 2018 s current clubhouse leader a
phrase of the year but when you do the
draft yes how often is bridge
quarterback going to come out that gonna
be a drinking game Dan the answer is how
often do you that's the answer first
segment I'm gonna guess bridge quarter
Bay like the Browns are on the clock now
they do have their bridge quarterback in
Tyrod Taylor well it's the Browns are on
the clock they've got their bridge
quarterback in Tyrod Taylor the Broncos
have got the Tyrod Taylor yeah I mean we
can go on and on so I can do it what
three times in the next hour or hold on
Giants choose a quarterback does that
make Eli Manning the mother of all
bridge quarterbacks a future in an elite
bridge Court would he be the Whitestone
bridge
nope Arizona I'm I'm more partial to the
Tappan Zee move it happens that's the
underrated bridge in the New York
metropolitan area he said but he's a sit
that's a system bridge that's we could
we could expand on this but it's bridge
quarterback everybody's got one nobody
wanted to go over pay even Kirk Cousins
is kind of the bridge quarterback to the
next one that they have is just three
years I mean that's a hot take on the
bridge by the way it's Kirk D cousins
what is the D stands for it's a middle
named I think it's David or something
but see I was I had somebody in the
Washington DC market who said that I
can't pronounce her cousin said like I
have it where it's like a tea not a Kirk
because a good curb stop for you yeah
there we go
Rich Eisen I was the bridge guest yes
you refer to get to see the audience
somewhere channel 239 riches show
following this one coming up at 9 a.m.
local time manifold Network codes back
in the final hour and Adam Sandler after
this for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]